Both user feedback and the UX review
are examples of user research.
A whole set of techniques used to
understand what users are experiencing,
and how we can use that information
to help build the best app possible.
In general, we can split user research
into two styles, quantitative and
qualitative.
Quantitative user research produces
data in the form of numbers.
How many users signed in, or
how long people spend in your app?
In many cases, this data's captured
indirectly via analytics tools
that can aggregate data
automatically across all your users.
Qualitative research, on the hand,
can't be reduced to a simple number.
Instead, the data produced here
is often via direct communication
between users and the development team.
In many cases, qualitative research
takes the form of interviews
that are either undirected,
in the form of our UX Review, or
directed with specific tasks or
goals for the user to accomplish.
For that reason, qualitative research
tends to be better at answering why
questions, such as why do
users disable notifications or
why do they like one
interface over another.
We've just touched on only a few of the
things that make up the field of user
research.
There's a ton more out there which can
help get your app production ready.
For now, let's focus on Sunshine.